diesen hashtag zusammen lernt man
weniger allein gegen gibt's tatsächlich
ich habe den mal genutzt um auch ein
bisschen werbung für die tagung oder für
das thema zu machen einfach und ich
würde mich freuen wenn irgend jemand
lust hat vielleicht auch ein paar tipps
zum thema soziale interaktionen
motivation in digitalen leeren räumen
beizutragen
sehr gerne einfach den hashtag auf
instagram nutzen und da ein paar ideen
mit dazu geben
tatsächlich ist es ja so dass uns alle
als lehrende eines vereins dass die
digitale lehre wahrscheinlich jetzt
durch corona uns so ein bisschen
aufgezwungen wurde beziehungsweise
stärker uns gefordert hat als wir es
bisher schon hatten je nachdem ob leute
sich vorher mit der digitalen lehrer
überhaupt schon beschäftigt haben oder
eben nicht so stark aber das ist eben
das was uns alle im sommersemester soll
ein bisschen ereilt hat und ich denke
tatsächlich dass wird auch nicht mehr
weggehen aber wenn wir uns eben mit
diesen digitalen leeren räumen und
lehrräumen beschäftigen die wir so
vorfinden kann man natürlich
unterscheiden das ist einfach auch so
eine generelle unterscheidungen die man
da treffen kann die wahrscheinlich auch
viele schon wissen in die synchronen und
in die asynchronen lernräume synchrone
lernräume sind beispielsweise die die
wir eben auch im moment schon gerade
nutzen oder eben auch an verschiedenen
hochschulen die virtuellen seminarräume
und da zähle ich jetzt nicht die
virtuelle konferenzräume dazu die
wirklich noch mal ein bisschen was
anderes sind die einfach nicht als
seminarräume konzipiert sind
ursprünglich aber sowas zoom big blue
button juling das sind so die typischen
programme die genau diese synchronen
lernräume darstellen synchron bedeutet
eben dass menschen sich treffen können
und zeitgleich miteinander lernen können
und miteinander an themen arbeiten
können
die asynchronen lernräume das wären
tatsächlich die lern management systeme
kurz abgekürzt lms die lern management
systeme wie wir auch nutzen bei uns zum
beispiel moodle
in anderen universitäten wird zum
beispiel auch elias genutzt es gibt
sonst auch noch andere plattformen wie
blinken mädels wer so eine
modellbasierte form die viele lehrer
kennen weil die jetzt bei dem
bayerischen raum auf jeden fall genutzt
wird von vielen schulen eben als
plattform die eben asynchron nutzbar ist
der entscheidende punkt an diese diesen
digitalen lernräume kann man noch
darüber diskutieren ob es noch andere
formen dazu natürlich gibt aber ich
möchte mich mal auf die zwei bereiche
fokussieren das meiner ansicht nach nur
ein optimum erreicht werden kann wenn
wir die wirklich in kombination nutzen
also dass der einerseits die
synchronizität nutzen indem wir leute
wirklich aktiv sehen können dann in
kontakt mit denen haben und asynchron
dass es da noch die möglichkeit eben
gibt leute einfach während ihrer zeit in
der sie uns nicht sehen eben dann zum
lernen animieren können mit so einem
lern management system das problem
tatsächlich was uns dadurch auch
widerfahren ist wir haben eigentlich das
erreicht was wir erreichen wollten und
zwar das social distanz singt dass wir
nicht vom krone virus hoffentlich
angesteckt werden wenn wir das ganze
online machen das war ja das ziel aber
dadurch dass wir dieses ziel erreicht
haben haben wir natürlich auch uns was
eingehandelt dass wir ein gewisses
social distanz inge erreicht haben da
wir eben in diesen digitalen lernräume
uns austauschen und eben da die lehre
miteinander verbringen und ich habe mir
eben die frage gestellt was sind
eigentlich die faktoren die es erreichen
dass wir dieses social distance in einen
digitalen nähern räumen überwinden
können und tatsächlich bin ich auf zwei
antworten gekommen die ich als zentral
erachte die erste antwort ist dass wir
eine kommunikationskultur in den
digitalen lern räumen brauchen und
entwickeln müssen weil tatsächlich habe
ich den eindruck dass darüber erstens
viel zu wenig geredet wird und dass es
diese kommunikationskultur also eine
digitale kommunikationskultur eigentlich
noch überhaupt
nicht vorhanden ist das könnte darunter
jetzt alles gezielt werden zu so einer
digitalen kommunikationskultur
ich glaube ein ganz großer punkt ist mal
die eigene haltung mit welcher haltung
gehe ich in so ein meeting oder in so
einer situation rein
ich finde diesen dieses zitat von
winston churchill sehr nette titel think
that makes the frames und dieser hund er
verkörpert für mich so ein bisschen
diese haltung mit der man auch in so ein
ein leerer raum reingehen kann weil wir
glaube ich das problem haben dadurch
dass wir in einem close up vor der
kamera sitzen sehen die leute sehr viel
von unserer mimik und können ziemlich
gut ablesen wie es uns gerade geht oder
einfach was wir von emotionen haben
und wenn ich ebenso oft in die gesichter
von den leuten schau in den virtuellen
seminarraum sieht man ganz oft so was
sie desinteresse oder einfach ablenkung
vielleicht vielleicht ist auch
gelangweilt sein ich hatte schon
studierende bei mir die so brad wright
in die kamera gewöhnt haben die das
bestimmt nicht negativ gemeint haben
aber den ist überhaupt gar nicht bewusst
gewesen dass man alles gesehen hat was
eben in der ist da auf dem video auch
einfach passiert und auch wenn man
gerade nicht im fokus ist ich sehe alle
immer als teilnehmer und auch die
teilnehmer sehen sich natürlich unserer
man da und wenn man da so ein bisschen
gelangweilt oder abgelenkt an an dem pc
sitzt fällt es einfach auf und da so ein
bisschen diese haltung zu haben zu
zeigen ja ich habe interesse an dem was
ihr passiert ist was was auch
kommuniziert werden muss und was auch
für von unserer weite vorgelegt werden
muss wenn ich mich schon nicht
interessiere oder auch sagen wir mal ein
interessiertes gesicht zeige
werden es meinen studierenden
wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt tun
der nächste punkt den ich ganz wichtig
finde ist vorab bevor man überhaupt
einsteigt so was wie ein check-in oder
ein und ein warmup durchzuführen
eigentlich sind es zwei verschiedene
dinge also der check-in da geht es
tatsächlich um so was sie
technischen check in ich habe schon
öfter erlebt dass die leute denken ach
die haben jetzt schon ein semester
corona hinter uns digital wir kennen uns
alle aus die studie ist kennen sich
natürlich auch alle aus wir sind alle
technisch total versiert da braucht man
nichts mehr erklären
tatsächlich sieht das ganz anders weil
ich stelle immer wieder fest es gibt
leute die dann eben sich mit der technik
noch nicht so gut auskennen
also schon allein so was was kann ich
tun dass ich eine stabile verbindung
habe also vielleicht könnte ich mal mit
einem lan kabel probieren wenn mein weil
es nicht funktioniert
oder halt einfach wie man zum beispiel
diese ganzen funktionen in so einem zoom
raum benutzt ja die benutze ich eine
umfrage was mache ich in den breakout
raum dass es eben alles was einer
gewissen anleitung bedarf und wenn ich
eben hier ein bisschen zeit dafür nehme
meinen leuten auch zu erklären wie die
technischen funktionen sind dann können
die sich auch einfach leichter dem
virtuellen seminarraum zurechtfinden
dazu gehört auch dass man
kommunikationsregeln einführt
kommunikationsregeln eben wirklich die
wollen wir uns in diesen raum begegnen
so dinge wie dass man auf stummschaltung
schaltet wenn einer redet das haben
jetzt mittlerweile die meisten begriffen
da gibt es ja auch ganz schöne videos
die die eben auch zeigen was passiert
wenn wenn das nicht eingehalten wird und
das sind eben genau die dinge an die man
tatsächlich denken muss dass man das
immer wieder auch neu noch mal
wiederholt weil viele leute das auch
wieder vergessen und auch die art und
weise zb so was die hand heben ja dass
er auch so eine kommunikations regel
dass man die hand heben funktionen nutzt
und nicht eben einfach rein brüllt oder
so das nächste jahr meiner ansicht auch
eine ganz wichtige sache kennenlernen
das ist natürlich schwieriger in
vorlesungen wobei uns da die digitale
welt dinge an die hand gibt die uns das
ermöglichen zum beispiel zum
kennenlernen kann man ganz schön so
dinge benutzen wie den chat das geht
auch bei 150 leuten dass man sagt die
leute können ja einfach mal rein
schreiben zum beispiel was sie am thema
interessiert
wird was ihre motivation ist hier zu
sein was sie vielleicht auch schon
wissen von vorher dass ich die leute
einfach auch ein bisschen ein gefühl
dafür bekommen wo stehen die eigentlich
ja man soll ja die leute mal abholen wo
sie stehen und vielleicht erfahre ich
dann auch ein bisschen was über meine
studierenden was ich vorher nicht
wussten dazu gibt es natürlich eine
ganze menge an solchen icebreaker
übungen die man am anfang machen kann
also der chat bietet sich dafür gut an
oder auch natürlich die annotations
funktion
ich machte immer gerne so übersichts
harz wo die leute dann eben auch an
notieren können auf einer powerpoint zum
beispiel so so was die motivation und
vorwissen oder wie viele weiß ich nicht
kurse hatten sie zu dem thema schon dass
man da auch einfach ein bisschen die
leute aus dem quark holt und sie dann
eben auch mal von sich preisgeben wo sie
tatsächlich im moment stehen und eine
sache finde ich auch noch ganz wichtig
die man nicht unterschätzen sollte das
ist die macht der stimme
und zwar nicht nur meiner stimme als
präsentator oder moderator sondern
tatsächlich die stimme der teilnehmenden
ich hatte letztens eine kollegin in
einer fortbildung das zwar nicht total
super die hat dann eben auch gesagt sie
macht es immer so vor den seminaren dass
sie auch den die leute allemal dazu
animiert kurz was zu sagen
in der vorlesung funktioniert das
natürlich nicht aber was ich zum
beispiel machen kann es auch mal
kleinere breakout booms zum beispiel
nutzen wo die leute dann miteinander
reden können weil das ist genau der
punkt diese distanz wieder zu überwinden
die stimme macht unglaublich viel aus
dass man mehr dasitzen menschen vor mir
und nicht irgendwelche leute die
eigentlich mir vielleicht gar fast gar
nicht zu hören
das geschafft unglaubliches vertrauen
wenn auch die leute untereinander die
stimmen mal höher naja ok die kennt man
dann einfach auch schon also die stimme
ist ein ganz wesentlicher aspekt den man
eben nicht nur von sich selber
preisgeben sollte sondern auch die
anderen dazu animieren sollte sich eben
aktiv da auch zu beteiligen
als letzter punkt halte ich auch für
unglaublich wichtig den persönlichen
kontakt eben immer aufrecht zu erhalten
weil das ist tatsächlich im digitalen
bisschen schwieriger
als wenn man die leute wirklich präsent
sieht wenn da eben die leute zwei meter
neben mir sitzen ich kann ganz viel von
der körpersprache ablesen das ist halt
hier schwierig wir haben halt nie mit
ihr aber alles was im körper ist sieht
man erst mal nicht und da ist dieser
persönliche kontakt einfach wichtig den
aufrechtzuerhalten damit man eben dieses
gruppengefühl diese atmosphäre schafft
von vertrauen die im digitalen raum oben
fassbar wichtig ist ein punkt ist das
thema in kontakt eins meiner
lieblingsthemen weil das ist ganz normal
wenn wir ihnen einen vortrag halten oder
einfach irgendwas erklären tendieren wir
dazu auf unseren bildschirm zu schauen
oder unsere teilnehmer anzuschauen ich
schaue mal auch so ein bisschen rechts
welches um eine leiste wo ich alle
teilnehmer sehen aber zwischendrin
sollte man immer mal wieder in die
kamera schauen weil die idee dass man
eben das gefühl hat man wird
angesprochen entsteht nur dadurch dass
ich den leuten in die augen schaue und
wie passiert ist in dem ich in die
kamera reinschauen und nicht irgendwo
auf meinem bildschirm ganz schwierig
finde ich auch immer leute die an so
nebendran noch mal so ein bildschirm
haben die dann immer so hin und her
schauen und meistens sieht man nur das
ohr oder hier so die seite von den
leuten besser wäre natürlich die
bildschirme zu staffeln so
hintereinander dass man dann wenigstens
eben immer noch gerade ausschaut
ich habe auch so einen kleinen trick
lieber meiner kamera habe ich so eine
kleine kröte als dicker sie lächelt mich
immer an die schaut immer nett zu mir
rüber und da habe ich auch das gefühl
mit der kann ich dann wenigstens ein
bisschen kontakt aufnehmen und ein
bisschen so eine persönliche beziehung
habe ich mittlerweile zu der schon
einfach nur dass es den eindruck macht
ich rede mit mir jemanden ja sonst ist
es immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig wenn
man diese linse schaut aber das ist halt
so ja sonst schauspieler trägt so spiel
mit der kamera so ein bisschen ich hab
halt meine kröte zweiter punkt was ich
auch ganz wichtig finde für diesen
persönlichen kontakt wir sollten es
schaffen eine kultur des gesichts eigens
zu etablieren
das ist genau so was auch nicht nur ich
als dozent sondern eben auch meine
studierenden sollten die kamera an
das ist bei manchen nicht geht weil sie
die weil das nicht funktioniert mit der
bandbreite serena aber im normalfall wir
haben hier wirklich glücklich hatte erst
letzten fortbildung in ruanda also nicht
in ruanda sondern online in ruanda das
schaut die sache noch mal ganz anders
aus wir haben hier wirklich die
möglichkeit dass die viele von unseren
studierenden auch einfach mit der kamera
sehen können und es macht für die
interaktion unglaublich viel aus wenn
man das gesicht der leute sieht dass man
da einfach auch das gefühl hat ja ich
rede mit menschen und das ist eine
kultur die man entwickelt das ganze
semester haben meine studierenden
wirklich die kamera an weil ich da
unglaublich viel wert darauf lege ich
zwinge natürlich niemanden ich sage wenn
es jemand partout nicht will aus
irgendwelchen gründen kann er das gerne
machen aber es ist was was ich einfach
versuche zu etablieren dass es wichtig
ist für die interaktion ich gehe auch
nicht im realen raum rhein ziehen damit
sie über den kopf oder oder eine tüte
denken ja es soll mich bitte keine
anschauen ja also das ist was was eben
eine kultur sache ist die wir
tatsächlich etablieren müssen da wo wir
immer auch immer wieder durch die
wiederholung merkens die leute auch und
man merkt einfach für die interaktion
hat es einen großen großen wert wenn man
gesicht zeigt und da eben auch sich mit
menschen dann auseinander setzt und
nicht mit schwarzen löchern
dazu gehört auch meiner ansicht nach
dass man die leute mit namen anspricht
das ist auch zum beispiel so eine ganz
praktische geschichte wenn man eine
frage in den virtuellen raum stellt
verpufft die viel stärker als in einem
normalen raum weil da hat man auch die
möglichkeit leute wirklich noch mal
genau anzugucken aber in einem
virtuellen raum fühlt sich niemand
niemand angesprochen und wärmten da kann
man sich wirklich trauen einfach mal zu
sagen na xy was sagst du denn dazu
syrien hast du dazu eine meinung wie zum
beispiel das ist auch nicht schlimm man
muss nur halt einfach die kultur
schaffen wenn jemand nichts weiß dann
weiß es halt nicht auch kein problem
aber einfach die möglichkeit die leute
ein bisschen eben auch aus der lethargie
raus zu nehmen indem man sie direkt
anspricht die sprache
ist natürlich unglaublich wichtig in der
führung weil das eben schon das
hauptmedium ist mit denen wir arbeiten
neben der visualisierung die man zum
beispiel mit powerpoint macht aber
tatsächlich die führung durch sprache
beinhaltet nicht nur den inhalt das ist
auch in der präsenz wichtig aber
virtuell noch viel stärker weil die
leute eben nicht sehen was ich tue
in der präsenz wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel zu einem flipchart vorübergehe
meine stifter suche das sieht jeder da
weiß jeder was gerade passiert
online ist es immer so ein bisschen eine
unsicherheit wenn gerade stille ist und
man nicht weiß was passiert jetzt wenn
ich den leuten aber sagen so jetzt teile
ich mein bildschirm mit euch oder jetzt
starte ich mal die umfrage aha ich habe
hier irgendwas im chat gesehen dass die
leute eben auf so einer meta ebene
geführt werden und man eben immer so
eine sicherheit hat ja ja ich weiß was
passiert das ist was diese metaebene
einfach mitlaufen lassen also ich rede
nicht nur inhaltlich worum geht es mir
gerade bei mir zum beispiel in der
literaturwissenschaft sondern auch wie
gestalte ich gerade den kurs und diese
idee der begleitung ist eben auch noch
längerfristig gemeint also an leiten und
begleiten
es braucht einfach digital eine viel
klarere anleitung und eben auch immer
eine kontinuierliche begleitung von dem
was man tut wenn ich so höre dass leute
halt so reine moodle kurse haben wo kein
einziges mal sich irgendwie mal
getroffen worden ist synchron
ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass da
manche leute ein bisschen überfordert
sind mit der situation also deswegen
immer dabei bleiben und die leute
motivieren oder auch in brück meldung
geben
das ist so auch bei diesen motivatoren
die man zum beispiel von spitzer kennt
ebenso dieses feedback was man
regelmäßig geben kann ist unglaublich
wichtig für die motivation eben am
lernprozess auch dran zu bleiben und
auch die klare anleitung also zb so was
wie muss eine aufgabe durchgeführt
werden zb in einem lern management
system
man kann bei ja auch zum beispiel nicht
nur schrift nutzen sondern auch ein
video von sich oder ein pott
dass die leute ein bisschen konkrete
einfach noch mal bescheid wissen was es
eigentlich zu tun
die zweite antwort auf die frage wie
überwinden wir dieses social distance
ist tatsächlich die interaktive leer
methodik in den digitalen lernräume wie
schaffen wir in die interaktivität und
man denkt sich ja ja ja ich teil halt
meinen screen und dann rede ich ein
bisschen dass das eine möglichkeit aber
es gibt wirklich so viel was man machen
kann ein interaktiver methodik die man
einbringen kann in seinen digitalen
leeren raum und ich kann jetzt nicht
viel vorstellen aber ich habe jetzt mal
so verschiedene gruppen mitgebracht aber
bevor wir da hinkommen würde ich gerne
jetzt noch mal die umfrage eine umfrage
starten und zwar zum thema interaktion
die frage ist wie häufig sollte eine
interaktion in einem online-seminar
eingesetzt werden so katja bett und ingo
geisler haben das auf der learntec in
einem vortrag erzählt und ich möchte es
war einfach mit euch teilen
und das wäre so die umfrage die jetzt
hoffentlich sehen könnt und die frage
ist eben wie häufig eine interaktion in
einem online-seminar eingesetzt werden
kann und wir haben die auswahl zwischen
3 7 11 13 17 21 und 23 minuten
was würden sie was würdet ihr meinen
bitte einmal abstimmen
das noch ein bisschen warten noch nicht
alle stimmen da noch 23 sekunden
na ja ist schon interessant noch 321
okay dann beende ich jetzt mal die
umfrage so elf minuten liegt vorne wobei
sich so ein bisschen variiert zwischen 7
13 17 21 minuten keiner für die 23 und 3
minuten
ja das ist wahrscheinlich eher so die
frage psychologie aber was ist
tatsächlich die antwort nach katja bett
und ingo geisler
sieben minuten also man sollte alle
hatten
man sollte alle sieben minuten sollte
man eine interaktion einfühlen
darüber lässt sich natürlich jetzt auch
zur tat schreiten ich finde es schon
auch echt ein bisschen hart sieben
minuten ist schon echt echt strahlen
wenn man da immer mehr interaktion mit
einbauen möchte aber es geht mir
eigentlich nur mal darum diese idee dass
im interaktiven arbeiten also wenn man
interaktiv sein will im digitalen raum
sollte man öfter interaktivität
einführen als jetzt in der normalen
präsenz lehrer das ist eigentlich die
idee dahinter dass diese abwechslung da
es um eben die aufmerksamkeit der leute
eben auch stärke aufrecht zu erhalten
weißen digitalen noch ein bisschen
schwieriger ist und jetzt komme ich eben
zu meinen verschiedenen kategorien was
es ebenso gibt an interaktivität was man
nutzen kann
das ist wirklich jetzt sehr überblicks
artig aber so die letzten paar minuten
dazu einmal die technischen funktionen
die uns die virtuellen seminarräume
bieten
da gibt es natürlich eine ganze reihe an
dingen die man nutzen kann
die den chat die reaktions buttons die
zeichen tools die man zur whiteboards
oder eben auch auf der power point
anwenden kann
die braker twins ich kann dateien
hochladen die handouts zb für die leute
ich kann links setzen dass sie sich zum
beispiel videos anschauen können oder
selber eben sachen eben nach gucken
können ich kann umfragen erstellen
ich kann die leute einfach mit audio und
video das wir da eben eine diskussion
haben das sind alles funktionen die ich
nutzen kann um da ein bisschen
interaktivität reinzubekommen
und das ist meistens das was eben die
virtuelle seminarräume auch bieten
technik technisch einfach ohne dass ich
überhaupt irgendwas dazu nehmen muss die
zweite sache ist die ich sowohl also
primär asynchron aber ich könnte sie
sogar synchron einbinden
denn wer ebenso lern management systeme
einfach haben dass wir eben hier die
aktivitäten einsetzen jetzt zum beispiel
dass es eben die ihr der übersicht die
übersicht von moodle abstimmungen kann
ich nutzen ich kann hier eben auch
zusammen eine datenbank erstellen des
ipads
studierende zusammen an einen text
arbeiten können ich kann sie sich
gegenseitig beurteilen lassen dass sie
dinge einreichen und sich gegenseitig
feedbacks ich kann auch interaktive
inhalte von außen einbinden also da gibt
es auch ganz viel was ich da eben nutzen
kann an denen an den dingen
ich kann aber auch ganz viele externe
tools nutzen ja das sind eben diese
ganzen programme von denen man immer so
hört eben von pingo mahara pat hearn
klick und so weiter und so weiter alles
an diesen programmen von denen man schon
öfter mal gehört hat aber sie vielleicht
noch nie eingesetzt hat das einzige
worauf ich da hinweisen möchte bitte
aufpassen mit sodingen die datenschutz
müssen die leute sich da in irgendeiner
weise anmelden
aber da gibt es eben eine ganz große
auswahl an dingen ob ich jetzt so ein
award wurde erstellen will die hier
wurde leute zum beispiel darauf stempeln
können was sie schon kennen
aufgrund der zeit lasse ich das jetzt
erst mal raus aber das wäre eben eine
möglichkeit zum beispiel oder zum
beispiel so was dass man so was macht
wie bei was wollte ich genau also sogar
mut solche quiz es eben die man machen
kann über suchfeld kann man zb sein
eigenes kreuzworträtsel erstellen
morel wer zum beispiel sowas da kann man
so wie karteikarten an die wand setzen
auch ein ganz schönes tool also das
unglaublich viel möglich wie man die
leute interaktiv einbinden kann
es gibt auch ganz klassische webinar
methoden die sozusagen schon man darf ja
bettina eigentlich nicht nein sagen ist
ja ein geschützter begriff und so aber
früher hier ist es ja noch so deswegen
gibt es auch einige bücher zu webinar
methode die würde ich dann auch noch mal
in den chats setzen dass man sich
anschauen kann
die eben extra für so virtuelle
seminarräume konzipiert sind
eine idee ist zum beispiel die web
quests die ich ganz schön finde auch vom
räumlichen her weil die idee ist dass
ich meine studierenden auf eine web
quest schicke dass sie eben selber sich
im virtuellen seminar daneben die
informationen holen müssen so eine art
heldenreise und es ist so der ablauf
dass man
eine gewisse einleitung schafft die
sollte natürlich vielleicht so ein
bisschen diese idee das ist auch so ein
bisschen schön illustrieren sie kriegen
eine aufgabe in denen auch der auch der
prozess die aufgabe ablaufen soll
beschrieben ist sie kriegen vielleicht
ein paar ressourcen an die hand zum
beispiel verschiedene webseiten die sie
nutzen sollen oder eine art lernphase
virtuell und wichtig wer am ende halt
noch mal so eine präsentation der
ergebnisse ohne reflexion von dem ganzen
dann eben auch dass dann eben nochmal
darüber reflektiert wird wie es
eigentlich diese ganze web quest
abgelaufen weil die normalerweise eben
auch in einer gruppe stattfinden sollte
das heißt dass da auch noch mal der
lernprozess in der gruppe reflektiert
werden sollte dass es eben auch auf
einer metaebene läuft die haben hier
miteinander kommuniziert wie ist die
arbeit abgelaufen war die arbeitslast
gleich verteilt und so weiter und so
weiter
und als letzte gruppe kann man sich
natürlich überleben gesetzliche offline
methoden online umzusetzen
ich habe nur mal ein beispiel
mitgebracht das wäre diese auf diese
methode singh persch erkennen vielleicht
einige leute die man normalerweise es
darum geht das die leute selber
nachdenken damit nachbarn nochmal über
das problem diskutieren und am ende man
gemeinsam eben über das ding diskutiert
online könnte man den leuten einfach
sagen schreibt erst mal für euch ein
paar ideen zu dem thema auf danach
entweder ortet man die leute in einen
privaten chat miteinander zu dass sie
über das thema chatten sollen
oder man setzt sie in zweier breakout
sessions und als letztes sammelt man die
ganzen dinge dann an einem whiteboard
was auch recht schnell geht natürlich
online weil jeder eben aufs whiteboard
schreiben kann und das muss ich jetzt
nicht als war alleine als dozierende
machen so also zum thema zusammen lernt
man weniger allein wie gesagt wer ideen
noch hat zum thema interaktivität gerne
posten unter dem hashtag ich freue mich
wer mitmacht ich habe das jetzt mal so
eröffnet und würde da einfach jetzt mal
ein bisschen daran weiterarbeiten noch
mal nur als überblick wir haben
zwei dinge wie wir eben dieses gemeinsam
lernen interaktiv und digital umsetzen
das eine ist die kommunikationskultur
das andere ist die interaktive methodik
zur kommunikationskultur zählt die
haltung dieser check in und format und
der persönliche kontakt und zur
interaktiven methodik haben wir eben die
verschiedenen dinge wie die technischen
funktionen die aktivitäten im lern
management system externe tools
spezielle wmi daad methoden und einfach
die übersetzung von offline methoden in
online methoden noch mal zur
zusammenfassung
soviel zum thema zusammen lernt man
weniger allein von mir und dann sage ich
danke schön und wer sich interessiert
kann mir gerne auch mal ne mail
schreiben ich freue mich über austausch
aber ansonsten auch gerne jetzt auch
noch irgendwelche fragen die da sind
dankeschön